لا يبدي عزيز وهو بائع الخضار في منطقه
الفاتح وسط اسطنبول تفاؤلا بشان استقرار
اسعار الخضار والمواد الغذائيه التي تواصل
ارتفاعها دون توقف عند حد معين
في الدول الاوروبيه في جميع المناطق الوضع
سيء فيها
للمره الاولى منذ عام 97 و 9000 التضخم في
تركيا يتجاوز
85% على اساس سنوي
نوفمبر الماضي عندما تراجعت الليره بشكل
كبير اثر قرارات متتاليه للبنك المركزي
بخفض سعر الفائده من ضمن سياسه سعى اليها
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان منذ فتره طويله
الى مستوى ما كان عليه في عام
1998 سبب ارتفاع التضخم بسيط جدا وهو
استمرار فقدان الليره التركيه قيمتها امام
الدولار الامريكي
الارقام الرسميه ما زالت موضع شكل لدى
الكثيرين بواسطه تقارير غير رسميه صادره
عن مجموعه ابحاث التضخم وهي مؤسسه مستقله
لتتبع التضخم في البلاد اكدت فيها ان معدل
التضخم السنوي تجاوز
185% وكانت الملابس الاكثر ارتفاعا في
اكتوبر الماضي تلتها اسعار المواد
الغذائيه التي ارتفعت باكثر من خمسه في
المئه
الشيخ يوسف نذهب الى البازار وجيوبنا
ممتلئه نشتري بعض الخضار والفاكهه ونحتار
لاي طفل سنعطيها لسنا بحال جيده الان
هذا الواقع اصبح جيدا لاصحاب المصالح لكنه
سيئا للقسم المهمش من الناس ستضخم الان
يذهب الى الاسود الاسعار ترتفع من تلقائي
نفسها
ويكافح الرئيس التركي وفريقه الاقتصادي
لخفض التضخم بشكل كبير قبل حلول
الانتخابات القادمه حيث يشكل الاقتصاد
عاملا حاسما في ترجيح كافه طرف على حساب
الاخر
رغم وصول التضخم الى مستويات غير مسبوقه
في عهد حزب العداله والتنميه لا يزال
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان متمسكان
بسياسته الاقتصاديه المتمثله باسعار
الفائده سياسه يراهن انها ستنجح في
النهايه بعكس ما يراه معارضون لكن المقياس
الحقيقي لنجاح او فشل السياسات اردوغان
الاقتصاديه سيقرره صندوق الاقتراع في
الانتخابات المقبله التي ستكون الحكمه
والفيصل زيدان زينجو العربيه اسطنبول